it can at points seem horrific ly clear
that simply no one really cares they
barely notice our presence they hardly
stick around to listen to what we have
to say they catch none of our hints and
they are overwhelmingly preoccupied with
their own projects and day to day
concerns on the basis of such evidence
it is easy for us to fall into a large
damning and dangerously heartbreaking
conclusion about our situation but we
are profoundly alone far beyond any
possibility of connection or empathy but
the truth may be at once more mundane
and rather more hopeful most of us
humans are extremely keen to help when
we notice an urgent need but we're also
continuously distracted grievously taken
up with our lives and unlikely to spot
that there is anything at all the matter
with people around us unless the problem
is spelt out in the clearest most
unambiguous terms then but only then
will we swing into action and bring the
whole of our intelligence and will to
bear on another's pains in other words
we respond well to screams but terribly
to hints the issue comes particularly to
the fore in tragic cases where someone
we know takes their own life we are
certain that we would if we had known
how desperate they felt have done pretty
much anything to help at the same time
we also know that we didn't inquire very
much didn't look too closely for hints
and must surely have given off an
impression of constant busyness we feel
understandably entirely wretched and
callous we would be wise to rehearse
these facts about human nature without
rancor or surprise when we are next at
our most fragile and desperate the
apparent indifference of others truly is
only apparent we need to learn to scream
sadly we tend to lack any confidence to
do so precisely when it would be most
necessary because the primal
embarrassment takes hold of us around
being in need as if it was in the remit
of any human to get through life by
their own wits alone part of the tragedy
of being desperate is how illegitimate
our agony feels to us yet we should
never allow ourselves to forget that
whatever the surface indifference of
others we are surrounded by people who
when they see an emergency in front of
them will jump into icy rivers to rescue
total strangers if we know unambiguously
that someone even a casual acquaintance
needs us a lot right now we will
probably drop everything and run to
assist but at the same time we are
hopeless at reading minds or taking
hints the next time we are in trouble
you must remember not to hate ourselves
for requiring help and should call out
hopeful in the knowledge that most
people around us will respond to our
pain once it reaches there is we need to
remember to scream a little louder and
hate ourselves a little less
we've just launched an app to help you
track down people with whom you can have
deeper more meaningful connections
follow the link on your screen now to
download it
you